but speaking of tone, I, I, I fully enjoyed, I mean, I, you know, I have set aside
you know, it's like if we're reading, I just find this to be true, if we're reading this repeatedly
like, you know, consistently, I allow, I don't get my allergy to his sense of authenticity kind of
dissipates and it just doesn't, I note it in places and then I just like, yeah, whatever, um, and move on
but like, yeah, for Heidegger, but I mean this is like, these chunks I thought were fantastic, like, I
really, and I was reading them faster than I would like to just because I've had a crazy week and I
was doing it this morning and was like, God, I wish I had more time with this because it's just very
very careful and and uh, although careful is a weird word there because it's also, I mean, he uses the word
you know, care, but it's also like it's just so I, I'm getting this, I'm making this mental connection
between Nietzsche's Genealogy of Morals, the third, the third book where he has a series of repetitions
of the refrain of um, about the, what is the meaning of the ascetic ideal? Yeah, and that that question
mutates throughout the course of that book and I swear like I'm very, I have not finished this book so
we've got three more lectures left and I'm I so far all this book is is or all these collections, these
lectures are, is a collection of series of quotes like this quote gets you to and spend time with
this quote for several lectures and it moves you to another quote and spend time with that quote for
several lectures and it moves you to another quote and I'm so hoping he doesn't tie it together like
I'm so nervous that at the end he's going to say so this is the final meaning of what is called
thinking or what I mean. Given what we just read, that would be really hard to do, although I will say
that that that the one that is probably the refrain for the book is that, you know, that which is most
thought thought-provoking, that which gives us food for thought and just frankly, you know, what is called
thinking and what I one thing I've loved about these lectures is I mean it took me you know several
lectures for this to start happening but now every time I read that what is called thinking I am getting
at it in a different sense, it is sort of opened up a little bit and I'm able to engage and explore it
differently more I I think that's that's very nice because you know yeah no I agree the clumsiness of
that syntax, you know, what is called thinking just threw me, but you know, I mean I'm really enjoying those
you know, the ruminations, it is it is ruminating and in this case it's it's the only time that I can think of
in Heidegger that I've read in Heidegger at least, um, where he really walks us through his creative
etymology, yeah, like with a leg like I mean this this series of the the Parmenides sentence, right, the
sort of translation of the Parmenides sentence he really slowly walks us through like each of the words
and yeah, and and and and why he's you know like not going with the conventional interpretation and why
you know and the relationship between his his you know the the true speaking of something in its essence
and the the commonplace, like it's just it's it's just much slower. He doesn't just do the wacky
interpretation and let it let it stand, he actually sort of walks through the process of making the
interpretation or the translation that he wants and it's really uh, I thought great, like I was just like
okay, I get it, I get you know why you want to make this move and why you insist on these terms and why
and like there's a one of my favorite moments is when he translates thinking is perceiving and then he
and then he says, um, um, this is on two or three so he's so we're getting now to the thinking word and
he says we we're going to translate this as perceiving yet nothing is gained if is if in this
translation we now replace thinking with perceive as long as we not do not become involved in what
that indicates in other words, like so just shifting the term from one term to another doesn't doesn't
do what's necessary or what he's trying to do that one still has to spend time with and ruminate I think
is exactly the right word like ruminate on you know why perceiving isn't passive it's active you know
the the thing that he stuff that he goes on to say but it's just the sort of you know I feel like I've
said that so many times with with students it's like you don't get out of a problem by replacing it with
a different concept like you still have to that that's a move and it's an important move but you don't
like oh now we're talking about hybrids or now we're talking about relations rather than objects right
like that doesn't solve the problem you still have to live with the notion of relations and show why
relations are not just some what that which happens between objects right for example what I love what
he's doing here is is showing that the vast majority of what we call thinking which is usually answering
questions or solving problems is precisely a flight from the anxiety or the difficulty of engaging or
involving oneself with a problematic and finding some external some internal problematic or some
external term that is going to fix it and fix it in both in two senses like one make it static
and knowable and then to solve, you know, solve the problem answer the question right right like I've
made it to the holy land right like I don't want to wander in the desert anymore I've made it to the
the holy land we found our, you know, hybrid networked ecologies and you know we know the answer is
sustainability that right i mean for you thomas the same move the same move that he makes with
perceiving he does with the word problematic where he says like you know it's a it's a problem you know
that problematic is the uh essence of the the habitat unique habitat and locus of thinking
but in but in view of the rashness of our public let us know something else it may easily happen that
soon even tomorrow the slogan is promulgated everything depends on the problematic you know
in every statement because you know and it's like so just as he said the problematic that's where the
answer lies it's like but no that's not where like as a simple statement so again it's like it is the
what's necessary is the rumination the movement the inhabitation i mean those are the different
sort of terms niches is rumination but you can't sloganize the problematic like and that was a
really interesting that was just like one or two sentences there right where he talks about that but
that was interesting to me because i was thinking about especially the early uh iterations of my project
where i was like you have to dwell in the problematic as opposed to offering sort of tidy solutions
and while i think that is basically correct i mean like as a philosophical or theoretical impulse
or even just an impulse pedagogically in any context i think that is kind of like that would be my
inclination right is to dwell in the complexity of a series of problems interrelated problems rather
than pushing for some sort of utopian solution but Heidegger here is saying precisely like if you keep
if that's all you say right that's becoming another brand that's another slogan yeah like you have to
always dwell in the problematic it's like well that you know it has lost the force you know uh but it's
lost a very particular kind of force that you know if the slogan becomes you know dwell in the problematic
then insofar as you feel safe and comfortable right doing that like and not i mean i think that there
is a kind of like essential i don't i mean suffering is probably not the right word but a certain central
anxiety that you know one has to yeah you know i mean if it makes sense to become comfortable with
discomfort um i mean like yeah you know i i like the way that he he he um uh brings that up with with
Kant on 179 toward you know the and this is sort of like you know look the very easy way of of taking up
that you know that phrase being is is to either say look there's nothing valuable here that offers
up no food of thought being is is basically tautological and you know maybe the most interesting
thing you can say about it is that it has become tautological because um you know here in the middle of
179 because thinking itself has slowly become accustomed to the idea which the sentence states in other
words this sort of like what is radically new for parmenides just sort of becomes commonplace in you
know history of western languages and then he turns to Kant to say that um you know Kant's like basically
that there's nothing unanalyzable about this concept of being that you just have to take it as sort of like
a first you know um brute fact and and he claims that is that the work of the concept that that allows
him to do this this is the very last you know line of um of that last full paragraph on 179
Kant's judgment that being belongs among the almost unanalyzable um uh concepts is indeed fully justified once
we share his assumption that what the words being and existence designate can be grasped primarily and
only in a concept that like you know the concept i mean literally with you know that prefix con there
as sort of you know inscribing boundaries around the thing and in order to be able to domesticate it
and of all things you would think that in some ways like being and in his relative staticness would
lend itself to domestication you know as opposed to say like becoming right because but you could imagine
it would be totally in the spirit of the heideggerian thinking to say um you know the equation of the
concept with grasping is a poor understanding of grasping because grasping is not simply a container
it is a fitting right like to grasp something means you have to have a handhold or what you know what
i mean like one could imagine doing that work of saying yeah like taking that a different one turn
further and it's really i mean it's it's kind of interesting here because it's like i've always
sort of thought you know hey look the kind of questions that we're interested are ones that just
don't have answers right there aren't there aren't something as simple as answers but i feel like
heidegger said something more important than that which is they they can't have answers it's important
that they don't it's not it's not just that they don't happen to it's that anything that takes the
function of an answer ends the thinking and so for for thinking to become involved it has to be an
inquiry that's directed and is a search but literally cannot right like an answer would
fuck it up right like the moment that you feel like ah i got it uh you're you're always looking
for that moment you're always searching to come to the like ah the the epip the epiphany or something
but once you have the epiphany you've got to keep like because that's what thinking is thinking is not
the uncovery of the essence it is the constant production of the uncovering and you're like that
to me is a that's a different step right like it's it's not just that these are unanswerable
questions that it's that it's like intellectually important that you not think you have answers
and we had this conversation oh go ahead nate i was just going to say that might be his uh his
departure from Kant here as well because even in Kant's bracketing of the noumenal or of being
right that there's a certainty in that bracket right it's like we constitutively cannot answer the
question of being because the concept gets in the way right and that's a yes or no that's like a
definitive claim of cons right we cannot do this we cannot grasp the thing in itself and whereas
Heidegger is obviously interested in intervening at that point uh differently than than Hegel is but
like right only if you think right only thing only if you think grasping and concepts are about
representation right right you know and here it's important he's right that you know he's like look
this is that i mean this comes out of work that is prior to the critique of pure reason and i mean
like critique of pure reason is only able to get up on the ground by saying the noumenal is
unaccessible and i need to feel confident uh that that um you know that the noumenal is inaccessible
so that i can clear a space to do the work on you know the logic of the faculty yeah exactly
it is a totally fundamental way of changing what thinking is because i mean like the very schemata
with with in which thinking is placed is always you know predicated on the telos of solving or
answering is that you know if thinking is insofar as you know the phrase thinking as a way of life
gets taken up is that like it's always the next problem i'm going to solve and then i'm going to
catalog all of my answers and catalog all of the knowledge and you know like because i'm such a
insatiable thinker you know i can't stop you know it's just how you know who i am essentially so i'll
find the next thing and you know that is so antithetical to what Heidegger's getting at here
it's like no the the as you said John you know the answering fucks up the thinking that you know
that just you know that that little storehouse of you know answers that you've done are only
dead thinkings that you you know that that you know have are now effectively not you know they're
not living anymore and you know so then the next way of of configuring that would be that all right
well then that means that none of these if they're not answerable then that's always a failure to
answer the thing which now imports a another orientation to the thing that you know there is
some answer in here it's just that you know because i don't know finitude mortality whatever else it is
i'm never gonna get there uh but that's still operating on the i think the same schemata and
and the the the change that needs to be made is that thinking is not paratactic on life that thinking
is nothing more than a modality of life which is to say that to dwell in thinking is just to live
a particular kind of of way it's a particular kind of you know invention within becoming of of life
that and you know that becomes very hard to justify in the academy because you know the academy is sort
of like set out at solving questions and problems and why are you going to pay somebody you know to
literally just think if they're not advancing or getting us closer to something that we supposedly want or
right i think we say aha so that becomes the necessity right like to me is it's important to think the
movement of thinking itself as the important part of thinking um because for instance there are
you could also say there are lots of answers in here right so he's he's constantly establishing
provisional grounds he's offering a different interpretation of Parmenides he's just he's not
saying one can't and one can't translate this yeah uh he wants to go after the unthought and he wants to
render the unthought thinkable right like in and and apparent right let it lay before us and so he's
doing all those things, but that that process is never uh completed, and it's never the right process
um so that it's it's like it's it's there are answers there are there have to be right there have
to be points where you're like okay i'm not going to call this into question right now right right now i'm
using this as my provisional background to call this other thing into question one can then return and
call that thing into question too right like and and as one can but so one is always just sort of
provisionally having that like this is a ground or a basis of unthought that is a condition for
thinking for thinking here and then that can be you know then you can have an inverted relationship on
those things but what you would have what you're after is the the whole process right like process
right because you you would have you would have to reconfigure what you mean by those answers which
wouldn't mean that they are provisional but wrong answers it would just mean that they are they are
you know um you know for their they're slow down a provision yeah yeah like yeah like uh yeah
singular like provisional singularities right that in their very activation will get unmade not because
they're not right not because they haven't fulfilled something right that by because in this context
they you know they work in this in another context they're going to be a different thing
yeah yeah um i mean that seems like a pretty delusian take on on heidegger here and i'm not saying
that that's wrong in any way but i do think like to be a little less generous as we have been at least
here and there like heidegger does seem pretty set on maybe not eternal answers that will be right
regardless of the context or their other application but he is invested in it as we've said in a kind of
authentic relation or authentic thinking or being that seems to transcend um at least the moment in which he's writing
right i mean like he wants to he wants to get after something that transcends the actual moment
uh in which he's embroiled right that's kind of the whole goal is to like is to is to reach towards
something that's not where he is i you know i i agree with you over and over and over again you know
the essence authenticity like a sense of like the proper comes up but that just so fundamentally flies in
the face of what he really gives a lot of attention to here in the language of you know translation and
interpretation and that frankly you know there can be no sort of like the notion of an objective
interpretation as itself a particular style of prejudice and you know the the kind of
virtue that a notion of inaccessible answer gives you is one of humility i have to be humble in the face of
never being able to succeed but what is what happens when success and failure is off of the table
it would have to give a very particular kind of confidence like it would have to be a kind of um
uh confidence in arbitrary like in in a kind of arbitrariness it's like it almost doesn't matter
which path i go down as long as i articulate it to its fullest extent and follow where it takes me and
this has a whole lot to do i think with what he's talking about of involvement and gets me to think of
his late notion of essence completely differently
you know nate wants to preserve the readings that we've been doing of heidegger against this sort
of delusian sounding thing but i i want two passages here the second of which i thought was just
awesome as a slogan but the first one is right after the chunk that you just read nathaniel uh on 192
but the time may finally have come to release language from the leash of common speech
it sounds just like the kind of thing that he was talking about there right and allow it to remain
attuned to the keynote of the lofty statement it makes and then this is the crucial part for me
without however rating customary speech as a decline or as a low right so in other words he's making the
distinction like there for instance in your case he's making the distinction between use and utilization so
utilization would be the instrumental human sort of for me thing and he wants to think something that's
not that without that utilization version being a negative or declined or less authentic or less
essential version now i don't think he really pursues the second part of that statement nearly as much
as he pursues the first part of that statement which is you know refusing language or releasing
language from the leash of common common speech and i don't think he really i just don't get the sense
he really wants to own or commit to the notion of parataxis uh that enables that there's a normative
sense of parataxis here at the same time i'm with you like if one hears essential nature as functionally
the equivalent of the overman in nietzsche that's pretty interesting right like i mean so in other
words that essential nature is the to be determined the sense of futurity as opposed to a retrograde
Reenactment of something that was there at the beginning, you know, right? You would have to multiply
essences that the essential nature of something is only realized in relationship to something else, and
and depending on what it's in, yeah, in its activation, so depending on what it is related to would
fundamentally alter its, its essence, and you know, I I in that language of affect, but it's still holding
and still holding on to the non-essential, non-nature, that is a constitutive element of that language
at the same time. Well, I mean, you can imagine relations that aren't particularly activating, that don't
particularly, that are relatively inert, right? I mean, the vert, the virtual that hasn't been actualized
yeah, which doesn't make it less real, doesn't make it, you know, lower. Talk about turning it into Deleuze.
We're literally taking the vocabulary, but I see that dynamic here. I mean, I I really do, right? That's
it. I see that, I see moments here where my aversion to authenticity, because literally, like two pages before
he's, he says something that I, I mean, I wrote, yeah, connect to like a speech far more primary than the
most exquisitely wrought sentence, and then that's right before the using, using, but that doesn't mean
utilization because utilization is the instrumental human thing, and I'm like, okay, yeah, that's the
bad version, but then literally two pages later he says what I just, you know, what we just read, which is
yes, we want to release language from the leash of common language, but without rating customary language as
a decline or as, you know, a low, like to me if you hold on to that second part or emphasize the second part
of that sentence, I mean the second part of the sentence is there, right? Like he's in other words
there's good reason for saying what he refers to as essential nature is what Nietzsche talks about as
futurity in the overman. Like, I think there is is a a way of reading at that, and it's not, and I go back
and forth as we've seen throughout these, like some of these passages just seem too wedded to that notion
of the proper and the essential as the sort of prior and authentic, but then there are the other
places where it's like, well, that notion of authenticity actually means go do something with it, right? Go go
take it somewhere, and this is this is the one, that the passage that I'm like, I want this slogan on on
our t-shirts or whatever, is on 201, where Plato in that famous passage, and this is, I mean, every part of
this I think is important, Plato sees something which every thinker has to see afresh each time else
he is not a thinker, that everything that lies before us is ambiguous, right? And that, but the crucial
part is it, it's not the slogan of everything that lies before us is ambiguous, but that every thinker
has to see this afresh each time else he is not a thinker. How, yeah, which would be to not sloganify
ambiguity, right, right? You know, and, and it's like so he is something determinate, right? Like everything
everything that lies before us is ambiguous meaning to be determined, you know, and we'll see, but I mean
to me that is, you know, I think perhaps ambiguity is his language of of the overman or of, you know
interpretation in that Nietzschean sense, is that the I mean essential nature is ambiguity and the thing
that he like, uh, is, is, you know, revolted by, uh, is a is uh the calcification of ambiguity, and that you
know, like the authenticity of anything is its capacity to become something else, right? And as soon as you have
determined the thing, you have that that is cutting it off from its eternal essential nature, which is
literally the opposite of what we think of essence. I agree, right? There there is good and there's good
reason, Nathaniel, I agree with you, there's good reason to read it that way, um, at times, at times it feels
like uh he's leaning more towards I mean it's it's interesting, right, to me, because why am I willing to give
Nietzsche this sort of uh leeway, and it's simply because his term for it is futurity. Like it's
always about the future for him. Heidegger doesn't write about the future, right? Like Heidegger writes
about a past and it's always a return or a kind of, you know, or the terminology of essence, and I think
that sort of temporal thing is why it's way harder for me to hear uh those those dimensions, you know, yeah
I mean this whole season has been dominated by that question of authenticity, and it is just
something that has agitated all of us. We're like, we all range from wanting to dismiss it because of
it or kind of seeing that, you know, something else is going on here that, you know, I mean talk about
like, you know, taking on someone's quest of trying to, you know, something that Heidegger seems quite
confident about, and we're like forcing ourselves, like, well man, I don't know about that confidence
like, but I'm also not, I'm also not, I also want to, you know, uh, steer away from just instinctively
uh, um, uh, you know, rejecting it either, but sorry I cut you off. No, no, it's all good. I mean, the only I
was just, I don't know why I'm playing the foil today. I mean, I feel like usually it's John or whatever, but
Uh, like with the kind of critique of Heidegger, but the only thing because I agree with you all
your points about essence, you could refigure it as a word for the overman or as a word for a
Nietzschean interpretation. I completely agree. I just think that Heidegger tends to like fetishize that
destabilize space a little bit, yeah, like where it's where it becomes like so the ambiguity that he's
after is obviously really interesting and he articulates it in ways that are kind of confounding
and and whatever and it's it's cool but I feel like he this is why I kind of lean back to Hegel because
Hegel is diagnostic of the tendency, like you said earlier, Nathaniel, to calcify ambiguity
right, so that calcification which is the enemy of Heidegger's he wants to get so far away from that
that he ends up fetishizing the alternative a little bit where it's like that's why he leans
he goes towards the poetic as an alternative to logos, etc. and it's not like that's a problem in
itself it's just that the ten like he seems to be reaching for something that for me is a it's a
little bit out of reach or it's or it's it's not that it's inaccessible or whatever it's just um
that's clearly a risk is but but that risk would be exactly the risk of sloganizing or calcifying the
ambiguous itself is is to never is to you know sort of like get yourself to the ambiguous clearing and
then staying there without actualizing any sort of line of flight would would would precisely be the
problem and this is again like where it comes back to a strange kind of confidence you know this is
i mean Heidegger isn't imperial or authoritarian in the way that we discovered that Hegel is but
he does have a weird kind of brash confidence in stuff that we're sometimes like did you really
substantiate that and you know it is nice in these few lectures where he really really does show the
work of doing the substantiation but you know it is a way of showing that if you're going to take this
ambiguity stuff seriously you need to make things with the ambiguity as long as you're as long as
you're clear that whatever you make is going to get undone and remade then cool but you can't just
stay in the ambiguity you have to make something with it to produce the new ambiguity I mean I think that
that I I totally agree with that and if one did like what boo boo is saying like the simple realization of
ambiguity being the case would not be a a thinker seeing it afresh each time right that would be
like you know that would just be like okay well I am that's the sort of fetishizing of like hey it's
indeterminate right and and so the the seeing it afresh is like I gotta fucking make something from
you know I I have to like it's ambiguous in its essence that means I have to hook it to something and
and make something out of it which of course will itself then be ambiguous but that's the sort of
movement of life right like and you have to continue to characterize that ambiguity each
time you have to not not to represent it but you have to kind of key into it somehow go through it
time rather than simply like designate it's not a state you're not simply recognizing a state of
affairs that is ambiguity right which would lend itself to like temerity or again humility but it's
like this is like the difference between you know he talks about um faith as being the enemy of of of
thinking you know there's like a difference between a faith or an assurance in what one has made and a
confidence it's like i'm gonna i'm going to confidently follow this thing that i am making
full and part of that confidence is not an antith like not you know an opposition to that confidence
but part of that confidence is knowing that it is not a bedrock that it is only a provisional
you know point of traction that will undo itself and and you know but i mean i think i think there's
a different sense of what Nate brings up that i i do want to hang on to which is that you know the
sentence that i pointed to which is without denigrating the common you know without rating customary speeches of
decline it's just not a point of emphasis for him that that second part right he he says it there
but like for instance why not I mean why not just say things in incredibly determined calcifying
ways that part yeah right like he does but but he well but he does do that with his that's the style
yeah I mean right yeah I mean and honestly like that's my style question it's like they're just
different ways of inhabiting the right sort of calcification de-territorialization calcification
de-territorial like they're just different ways it is an odd qualification though because he doesn't
say that really anywhere else and I didn't catch that on my reading like the the part you pointed out
where he kind of allows for the common speech to even just exist like in other places he's very
just denigrating of it it's not common for him to rate common speech as not being less than or a
failure, or a falling away from, I mean, I agree with he does there. There are, there are a handful of
mentions. There are places. There are, in the previous lectures, and then even here, you know, like he does
the he he wants to make sure that there's like he wants to eschew a kind of progressivism right i
mean with paratactic syntactic, right? He wants to say that like wine isn't, you know, the white
parataxis is not simply, you know, a stage on the way to syntax. Syntax and that, you know, this pre-Socratics
are just not as way. Like he's, you know, uh, these aren't, these aren't developmental steps, and he doesn't
even want to say, you know, like he doesn't want to say like some primitive language is, you know, like
the primitiveness of it isn't some sort of like underdeveloped notion of, you know, some other refined
things. So, you know, that, yeah, yeah, to me that, I mean, that is it cut from the same cloth as that
is that claim. I mean, what I do think maybe the location here is some kind of conscious like raising
consciousness raising that, you know, uh, um, you don't near utilization is a problem when you have faith
that you have, you know, done the work and then that somehow makes it less inventive. I think your
intervention John's like that makes it no less the fact that you don't know that you're being
inventive and the fact that you you know think that you have found the the the right answer in no way
shape or form makes it any more or less inventive. This is where remember like that, what is rhetoric
essay that I wrote 20 years ago or something where it's like look, I mean, there are many ways of not
answering the question what is rhetoric and one of them is answering the question right because that
has, that has never stopped people from defining rhetoric when I said like the final and absolute
definition of rhetoric is x it doesn't stop anyone else from defining rhetoric right it gives them
coordinates from which to offer diverging definitions so that in that sense the calcification is what enables
the itinerary right it's not calcification versus i versus de-territorialization it's like you don't
have de-territorialization without a point right um, you know, something from which one responds and that
point is not simply you know the the point itself as a point is not determined you have to then figure
out what the point is in order to diverge from the point but you think about it from like evolutionary
biology that you know it's oftentimes the trendier thing to do is to say look like at mass extinction
extinction events and see them as um, inventive catalysts right uh because you know because it's
a de-territorialization it's a decalcification but then you could also say that you know the singularity
of any sort of i don't know like over determination of biodiversity or like stagnation or climate change or you
know call it the anthropocene or whatever it is like the particular configuration of that
hypercalcification is also going to be a pretty strong influencer on you know say a mass extinction
event or some other sort of like inventive divergence or whatever it is right it's going
to provide the contours you just have these dynamics of like movement and rest and by the way
you don't even know which is which right like this is this is where to me if you really want to get
into de leuze's concept of de-territorialization and re-territorialization you have to say they're the
same fucking thing yeah right like they shouldn't be two concepts they should be one concept right
yeah right like i mean they're two senses of the same concept two senses of the same concept
yeah yeah i mean to go back to the issue of of common speech real quick though i mean it seems to be like
like his his primary concern is that we are resting in this mode of thought right you need to shake
those those kind of conservative foundations but you brought up nathaniel like how the how heidegger's
actually kind of progressive in his thinking of like primitive speech versus like paratactic versus
syntax and etc like pre-Socratics versus socratics one does not like lesser than what comes after i
i wouldn't say he's progressive in it but i love the idea of progressive he's uh he's at least
conceptually he's progressive about his anti-progressivism yeah exactly exactly he's a very
progressive fascist. Um, um, but the issue with uh, with modern communication or with common speech
representational thinking is not that it's primitive or that it's pre-Heideggerian right it's that it's
like too too advanced almost oh absolutely it's gotten too technical too technical and it's too
successful all the time yeah right like and he kind of he makes the admission like we wouldn't have
automobiles we wouldn't have any of this technology without this kind of thinking but it's created a
a series of problems in its own right like sort of secondary or or whatever like residue residual
issues with this this type of thinking right but but the difference is for Heidegger then he says and
What and one of the problems is it's made thinking really difficult to do as opposed as opposed to
here's another way of taking it: it's made thinking possible for the first time.
Right, that other claim, like in other words, because he wants there is this sense of, like, thinking was more
possible and available, although there's these moments where he does, he says, right, like, it was available
prior to the representational of vacation of of language and thinking, like prior to that something
was sort of available that has lost its availability and now requires a labor to make it available again.
But you could say, but if that labor is right, that that calcification is what enables Heidegger to be
possible, right, like, and and not because he's getting behind it, you know, you know, historically or etymologically
or whatever, but because, like, that's the condition for, like, that calcification is is the thing that
allows for a jumping off to an uncalcified, right, uncalcified, or to, you know, just to switch the metaphor a
little bit away from bones and more toward knots and ropes, is that, you know, the only way that you're going to be
able to start, like, following the Gordian knots or sort of, you know, like, following the twists and turns
of the thing is for the knot to get tied in the first place, not to get tied, right? If everything is you
know, sort of like open and ambiguous and pure potentiality, then there's nothing to reactivate.
There's nothing to activate differently; there's nothing to sort of, yeah, and he does, he kind of
he kind of says that about the Greeks, right, that they they lived with this the sort of like the seed
of this becoming in their language, in their being, but they didn't have any way to articulate, they didn't
they didn't conceptualize it, yeah, they couldn't conceptualize their moment or their way of relating.
But they were relating differently, that's right. It was there. It was their milieu. Here's one way of of
saying all that we're saying: it is useful for the rock to have shafts and for the earth furrows, it would
be without welcome, without stay. That's the holder in moment, but that's what it's saying, right? Like
rocks have cracks, right? Like uh, and it is useful and that is welcoming, I mean, I think that that's you
you know, these hard things have, but now he wants to emphasize the the the shafts, the cracks in the
rock are the thing that's cool, uh, you know, it's like, well, no, what about saying the rock without
the fucking rock? You wouldn't have a shaft, right? Like, um, so it's just, it's a question of that's where
to me it's a it really is a style question of where's the emphasis, what's the primary? Is the emphasis on
change, transformation, and movement, or is it on stasis, even momentary and provisional, you know, stasis
salinity, stability, you know? Yeah, and and again, the problem consistently is not to think those things
as opposed relations, right? To say like, look, you only get the movement with the stasis. I mean, you only get
the shaft with the rock. There there is no shaft without a rock. I mean, this is where you kind of, sorry,
just well, I don't know if it's going to be that quick, it'll be quick enough, you can get to your
point, but it's just like I feel like take the time, um, I feel like Foucault and anybody who basically
takes up Nietzsche, uh, in in a way that's anti-Hegelian, um, they do this thing where and it's really
interesting and it's like almost the it's like the the pinnacle of anti-Hegelian discourse where
you have an ontological um, I guess you could say deadlock where for Hegel, right, like subjectivity
is a constitutive condition and it has all these constraints to it, right, like so like we talked about
the understanding and stuff like that, how it calcifies, it appropriates it, it does all these sort of
rigidifying, reducing, simplifying relations, and that's the bad guy for most of post-structuralism
for for Nietzsche and all that. So they kind of they what they try to do and and successfully and
interestingly is they impose or superimpose like an ethical demand into an ontological deadlock, so
there's an impossibility possibility like threshold there that's just continuously um interrogated
right over and over again in Nietzsche and Foucault and Heidegger, and it's that tension
right that seems to produce all of this uh scholarship as opposed to like stifle it.
If it's if it's a if it's a tension, right, like that's exactly what I'm saying, like that's the
dialectical framing, right. There's a I was gonna say Nate, the only thing I learned from the Hegel Tapes
might be that no one has ever been anti-Hegelian, right? Right, yeah, yeah, yeah, well, I mean, you can't, you
can be, I mean, plenty of people have claimed to be anti-Hegelian. Oh, they can claim
which would put them, yeah, they can claim anything they want, but as soon as you run that anti-line you are just churning out
the the Hegelian machine. There's an obvious irony there. Yeah, yeah, you get you get caught, right, is
immediately when you say it, you're caught. Yeah, but I don't know, I I don't think it makes my point is
not that there's like naivete in the in the effort to make the this kind of ethical or conceptual demand
on Hegel's ontology to try to to try to get past it is pretty noble I would think I just it's
obviously extremely difficult I mean but I think so someone like Derrida for instance has no
interest in getting past it and it will would critique the very effort to try to get past it
you know that well there is no getting past that that not well getting past I guess Derrida is
certainly interested in something different from yes and no right like it's it's it's different but not
different from right like I I think there's many Derrida's too it's like this is this is why I want to
read that this is why I want to read that essay because the restricted to general economy essay
at least when I scanned it the first time it seems very like post-Hegelian like almost explicitly like
the restricted economy is a galion what I'm offering is a general economy so it almost and I'm not saying
it's not like some that's right you're you're right no that's true that's right that's my reading of it
I mean he is offering something else whether it's whether it's structurally opposed to the dialectic
is up for question but well but whether or not that's something else is unavailable in Hegelian
is I mean again the difference would be again like Hegel can become the thinker of absolute contingency
right like as and so anything can be right but but the point I I take the crucial point there is that
the thinker has to see it afresh see the ambiguity afresh each time which is to say
um I I I take this from like the Losez uh in Thousand Plateaus where he says multiplicity is a
constructivism it's not the ontological case it's not like shits multiple yeah it's that multiplicity has
to be made right it has to be produced so it's not an it's not in a sense you'd say there is no
ontological claim here um or the ontological claim is performative or a signifying which is
it has to get made now what gets made is ineluctably multiplicity regardless right our affirmation in
the Nietzsche register that's what gets made but it's not just there and so that's that hinge of like
it's ontological that's where you know Derrida call it the ontological or whatever it's like it's
not just that there is multiplicity or there you know it's that it all that ever gets made is
multiplicity and active force but right right you know well and that I don't want to get I don't know
why I brought up Hegel we didn't really necessarily have to go down this line but that's the difference
if I had to dive for every time he has said I don't know why I didn't mean to I didn't I didn't
bring up Hegel it's not my fault you own he usually means to yeah yeah usually I just mean to do it
this time I didn't mean to but I mean you're like you're it's just like my project is just and I had
to write a little bit today so I'm just thinking about it yeah um that's the difference between like
Barad and Deleuze right is that for Barad now again if you want to be generous with her maybe there's a
different reading but for her there's stuff out there right for the taking for for observing and
all you have to do is get the right coordinates and you can access the in itself for Deleuze that's
not the case I mean everything is like you said constructed and every variable is on the same plane
but he thinks that in a way he thinks that basic principle of the flat ontological plane with a
rigor that is not available in most of these kind of like post-humanist versions I agree with you but
what if you said that and I I think there's reason to read it this way it's been a long time since I read
the universe book but what if you said that her that ontological claim is a provisional claim
right which is to say okay for for the you know for present purposes let's assume that there's the
truth is out there or you know that we're going to find it and it's in relation right like relation
is uh the place where we find it well you wouldn't you I mean to me you would have to undo
like the the content of the claim would have to undo the structure of how you got there
right it would you'd have to complicate the move of like okay there's a there's a there there there's
a truth out there um and the truth is relationality well if there if the truth is relationality then it
can't simply be out there yeah right it can only be relational so in other words by the content of the
thing that you find there is going to subvert the the thing that drove the inquiry in the first place
yeah right so um and I think there are good reasons to read that in Barad I do too I mean
because the other thing you could say is the truth isn't out there as relationality the truth is out
there as relations and if you're going to think about a relation as a singular intersection point
then you're going to say all right then you know the truth is I mean in some ways like universal because
Any relationship follow it out and it connects to literally everything else and so like you know
Any particular configuration is that that provisional truth that is, you know, i'm sure it's it's undoing
and remaking itself, but if that's what you want to call truth, you just couldn't call
a truth anything that we would normally think of it as as like a self-contained it's not an answer
right i mean it's not yeah it's not it's not self-contained descript yeah it's not a self-contained
entity and it's not a description that captures the um you know that that can bound one thing off
from everything else that truth would truly have to radiate you know infinitely or or the next step would
be well of course you can claim that because it's not going to work that way anyway so you can claim
anything that you like this is a totally but you know what i mean like you could just take you know
follow it out further like yes this is this is the absolute truth there is no possible deviation from
it and then see what that makes right all i would say is that i mean i don't like that version because
it usually you know it has a way of leading itself to genocide yes it does yeah there's some issues with
that all that's an invention genocides are inventions just yeah you know not my style again it's a style
it comes back to the style question to me yeah it's like yeah all i would say is that broad
rarely if ever engages that kind of recursive interrogation of her own movement of thinking
so it's available like you can make those moves that you were just talking about john where you kind of
repurpose relationality within the context of the project but she just doesn't do it for the most part
and she's not and she's way too confident in the mode of analysis it's like we talked about with heidegger
once you say that you know dwell on the problematic once you sloganize anything
it's all phenomena it's all relationality it becomes not only meaningless but like
conservative like it becomes a conservative right and we are looking for a kind of Hegelian
reflexivity i mean you and i we all are looking for that as this you know like when i said you know you
can find it in heidegger it's here we're looking for evidence of that sort of self-awareness of the
constitutive problem because that allows us to like it more or dislike it less maybe but i'll give
you an example last night i was talking to a grad student who's doing a thing on broad and broad uh
is use of pronouns the here her they whatever and it's broad and butler and they have both
chosen to use the word they like that's what they put in their little oh okay and she was talking
about she's she's like yeah i watched this youtube uh talk that barad gave at duke and uh it was on
non-linear time and um so she gave this talk and she had slides and whatnot and she said there was an
asterisk on uh the first slide that stayed up for a while and the asterisk said um you're going to have
to excuse the totally linear quality of the presentation that you're about to see right
like and and it's a joke it's uh to me at least it's super obviously a joke but what she's doing
there is recognizing the conditions for you know the thing that she's going to proceed to problematize
but in order to problematize that i must proceed linearly you know in order to and and so to me it's
that kind of moment where i'm like okay cool right like yeah you know that that makes it less
disagreeable so that i'm not going to be like ah performative contradiction right yeah um yeah so so
and at least for me in my engagements with Barad which is far less than yours and you know um i see
reasons to be like oh yeah i see her doing that i see those kinds of moves occasionally that are enough
and again for me the stakes are different than they are for you right like for me in terms of my own
intellectual itinerary i just think like okay the kind of work and thinking that she's doing is a
generally good thing i don't care or a positive contribution to thinking in rhetorical studies
right um because that's just doesn't there's isn't very much of that yeah um so but i totally but
that doesn't mean that i disagree with your claim because i don't right like i i see that yes she's
calcifying and she is you know projecting a kind of positivist right version of this relationality
being ontologically primary i i see that too i don't think that you're wrong so it's it's it's a
question like i get Nate Nate wants to do that it gives him a thing to do and you're building something
so just make it cool yeah i mean and i hope i'm in productive disagreement i mean a lot of it is a
lot of it is pretty confrontational uh mostly just with Barad now these days though like my i was gonna
try to take that or i initially i wanted to be confrontational with Deleuze and then even with
Foucault when i learned that he was anti i was like well wait i kind of like both Hegel and Foucault
Why is he pitching himself like this, and I was like, do I have to hate Foucault now? And I'm like
no, I don't have to hate Foucault. You know, you can negotiate the relationships between these kinds
of things. You got your Hegel tattoo and you can't flash your right, right, you have to stay in your
territory. Now even further, I would never want a Hegel tattoo or to fly the Hegel banner, right? Even
though he's kind of this become the centerpiece of this project, the whole notion of being, like, of
having a full-throated, right, is is at least I want it to be foreign to me even if I am kind of like
leaning Hegel. I would never like pitch Hegel as a product, but I get that and that that is a question
of identification, right, that we all we all negotiate. For me, for instance, it's like at this stage of the
game I wouldn't have a problem with that because I'm it's very clear to me that Foucault's Hegel is
different than my Hegel, right? Like that's just clear, yeah, that it's not, and not because Foucault's
is wrong but because Foucault lived in a different moment and did different, you know, like, yeah, so
it's like, oh yeah, that's fine. So for him Hegel was the bad guy, and I understand why Hegel was the bad
guy but I have, you know, Nate via Zizek's version of Hegel and then our reading of that in in my head
when I'm thinking. So I'm like, actually, there's a different Hegel, like there's not, there's not one
Hegel, right? Right. So and that Hegel is a more interesting one. It's still one that you know I
maintain a kind of identificatory distance from, and that's a primacy of negation, right? I mean that's
for me the tone, right, right, like, and that's and that's the thing that I like about Nietzsche dare
not to lose these folks who are like there's just joy rather than labor, right, like as this sort of
primary emphasis. But is it imaginable to me that in 10 years I might think differently about those
relations entirely? Like it's entirely imaginable, but I don't. So you know, so that that's all, like
I can I can accept other people's negative relation without any, you know, it's not like, oh well Nate's
not really thinking this through because he's he's sort of positioning Broad in this particular way.
It's like no, but Broad is totally susceptible to being positioned in this way. It's not wrong, it's
not bad, it's not sloppy, and it's not straw manning, it's none of those things. It's right, and there's
also something else available, right? Yeah, I was thinking Nate, what what even about just including your own
asterix in, you know, as a part of your dissertation that's sort of like, look, I understand, I actually
could, you know, I I'm very tempted to write a very generous account of Broad because you know she's
interesting in all these registers and I think, you know, whatever whatever whatever, but given you know
the the lying of thinking that I'm producing here I'm going to articulate her in this in this way, it's
not because I finally think that this is the right answer but because it allows a certain kind of allowed
allowed me allows me to get a certain kind of traction. So, you know, what is at stake in my
critique of Broad is not a dismissal of her. In fact it is, you know, the condition of possibility for
a line of thinking. I think that's a good idea. And yeah because I was working on the intro today and
I had just I hadn't looked at that. It's basically like a repurposing of my proposal and I haven't
looked at my intro since I did the proposal and it's all extremely like uh dismissive for the most
now you know why we had the uh proposal meeting that we had, right, right? Yeah, yeah, um. But it just took
him two years to understand the proposal meeting. Yeah as I've continued to write though it's not that I've
become like less um confrontational with her texts, it's just that a lot of times like you're saying
like I could put these little conditional or qualified qualification like remarks and I do that
I actually do what you just said with uh but that's more so because I feel like I have at least a
provisional relationship with them and I will be seeing them all the time so it's like I need to say
something here and I mean it, it's not that I don't mean it absolutely. I'm basically like listen I think
your work is worth challenging, like that's the reason why I'm taking some of this stuff to task
because you are the most advanced theorist, some of the most advanced theorists in the field so why can't
I not? Like I I feel like it it's it does justice to the work, um, to act to not to critique it or to
criticize it but to get into the weeds with it, and if you confront it what does that do, right? Like
confront some of the presuppositions that might be, you know, uh, underlying your words. Why don't you
write an afterword that is about like the question of negotiating intellectual subject position, right?
Like, which is all that we're talking about, and and the complexities of like, yeah, there's part of me that
thinks that the the sort of, you know, John's version of this is is available and I can do this uh but that
prevents me from having this as a hinge to do this other kind of thing and I have a kind of aversion to
what I smell is the positivism but uh but I sense that there's a way of complicating that positive because
by the way I have the same reaction that you do which is I smell the more than a hint of positivism in
there it just doesn't bother me right um because that's just not the itinerary that matters to me
in the context of her work so it's not like I'm you know I don't think well geez it's not there
fucking boo-boo's making it up again um it is more just like where I am and in terms of the thinking
that thing doesn't it's not and and so to me that's the difference right between you and me in that
regard it's it has nothing to do with being right or wrong it has everything to do oh I gotta admit
him again everything to do with like sort of how you're thinking through it right and so to me that
would be a fantastic afterward of like look one of the things that I'm negotiating here is my
relationship and the sense of identity with which I connect myself and have increasingly connected
myself to Hegel and that has forced uh not that one particularly but any of them we all do this
forces a kind of you know okay so I like to lose that means I'm supposed to like uh Foucault uh that
means I'm not supposed to like Hegel it means I you know what I mean like the sense of into intellectual
affiliation which lends itself to how we read the stuff and which things we're willing to be generous
with and which things that we're not right kind of dispositional responses to scholarly texts
milieus entire discourses that's right the field right like like yeah the existence so for instance
a big thing that's governing my uh uh willingness to to not get irritated by that fact is my understanding
of the field of rhetorical studies which is like I get that there's a more than a hint of positivism in
there but it doesn't bother me because she's smart as fuck and thinking through interesting questions
and I want people in the terrain that I'm concerned with the rhetoric folks to to think like that yeah
you know yeah no that's good yeah because I've been writing recently a lot just about that problem of
like and it's not something you can really get behind you just you almost just have to speculate
sometimes like right why people are responding in the way they are to certain texts or or whatever like
for example uh Butler and Zizek have this dialogue in this in the joint book that they have and they
have all these pretty hostile um exchanges with each other over the years and I'm and I'm just like
asking the question like why would these typically pretty careful scholars now Zizek is an asshole all
the time but Butler that's his thing rarely is but like why are they basically getting in like Twitter
beefs in a scholarly format like what what would compel them to do that and Zizek basically explains
it like this is a problem of identification he's like listen Butler and I share so many presuppositions
about scholar about how the world works or everything that you couldn't even list them and so the the issue
is like we're trying to carve out our identity and sometimes that's a hostile fucking thing to do
not sometimes always always right it's always a question of cutting off violent carving right it's
yeah yeah right like I'm a distinctive self I am not Judith Butler right and and this is and so yeah
it's volatile because that fucking really matters that's exactly why at least for me the interest in
non-recognition and disidentification becomes really important not knowing who you are not being a major
public figure right like not having that that sense of stakes you know that's to me one of the things
that Nietzsche is great on is like I'm going to occasionally say stupid shit about things because
that way you won't fucking know where to situate me and neither will I yeah right it's at the beginning
of Ecce Homo whereas like I won't even know how to situate myself and that's part of the project like
I don't know where I you know find myself in the in the annals of philosophical history like that's
what compels me because he recognized that problem a long time ago and said I'm gonna say dumb shit
like to bring it back to Heidegger when we take it this way we must come to the point where we in
thought and inquiry retrace the questioning of a thinker by starting from his own thinking and from
nowhere else this task differs in every respect from the frequently heard demand that we must
understand a thinker in his own terms that is impossible because no thinker and no poet understands
himself how then could anybody else dare claim to understand a thinker even to understand him better
and like again not as a failure but right right right yeah so but I I love that so basically you
should write an afterword on style yeah I should put some of that in the intro though you're right
like I I just sent the intro off the back because Byron was like I want your introduction I was like
Well, I don't have it but okay I'll uh whip it up for you but that that would be good to kind of just
because that not only does it provide some like uh what's the word like some like leniency or like
just some kind of qualification qualifying remarks right but it also reshapes kind of the whole
trajectory project because the middle chapters are very much invested in that question but the the
proposal which is serving as the intro did not explicitly articulate that so yeah like getting at that
how do people negotiate their relationships with each other in a scholarly setting where you're supposed
to be objective but everything is infected with these weird idiosyncrasies your you know your
affections your your team affiliations yeah yeah all that what jersey you're wearing all that
and and i'm not and obviously i'm not insusceptible either so you kind of have to make
make that move as well like i don't want to be team Hegel but i could see how this project
comes off as team Hegel you know of course right that's where so i mean that's a cool thing so your
project became like the the condition of possibility for your project got undermined as you did the
project right that means you're a thinker right like in in Heidegger's terms there right like the
seeing afresh the ambiguity that's the unspoken of your statements yeah and we all live up to Heidegger's
standards his slogan his sloganeering standards right so yes yes so you too could be a nazi maybe one day
I'm still young.